hey guys Perry and Riley here and we've
got a fun little video to share with you
right now because in case you didn't
know so low a Star Wars story it's
currently available to own on DVD and
blu-ray we've got our copy right here
but that's not all we have on the table
right now Riley we are about to unbox
this gentle giant Nissan exclusive range
trooper helmet and yeah I'm a big fan of
stormtrooper armor so the fact that we
get to do this right now I'm pretty
pumped
yeah I'm pumped to look at this thing I
mean when you tell me there's a full
range trooper helmet I'm with you I love
the designs of the stormtrooper mask
always have
I like the expansion in the stories
where we get more troopers when you go
oh yeah what do they do when they're in
swamp what do you do when they're on
sand what do you do
we're in whatever this guy all right I
think we should unbox except I can
barely see your face over this I know
it's this box every one is bigger than
Perry it's pretty good this thing's
including Joe Goddard so we got a what
we got here is a actually on my
tippy-toes right now are you on your
tippy-toes of course you are so this
looks like limited edition we have
number 100 out of 100 so we got the
lucky number 100 certificate of
authenticity hey like it love it is the
real deal can't put this to the side I
think we need to tilt it over right oh
my god I think we need to do this yeah
yeah this thing is really coming I mean
they're not they're not screwing around
with this thing okay all right here we
go
okay we're gonna put the put the box off
to the side here oh my gosh this thing
is taped up good and tight here we go
all right I need something to cut there
we go all right I want to be very
careful here because I don't want to cut
the innards sure that's the horror lover
yeah I know right almost there
oh oh wait wait do you want to do the
honors oh there's gloves yes I'm gonna
do the honor I learned anything from
Jeremy John's it's you only handle these
toys with a pair of creepy white gloves
this is hysterical
alright I'm gonna be Mickey Mouse I can
at least open the stand yeah okay I
don't want to get you know you don't
want to get any oils on the collectors
this thing is rad this has like a new
car smell it really does alright oh boy
this thing is heavy I mean this is the
real deal here okay we're getting rid of
this yeah
always save the original packaging is
that what they say I have no I don't
know okay we're going I don't have any
storage in my apartment for the original
packaging this helmet is bigger than my
apartment all right so we're I'm just
doing it I'm opening oh my god smell
that new car smell
new cut nude new range trooper smell
that is beautiful
alright cuz look I mean is it heavy it's
heavy touch it yeah touch it I just
washed my hands yeah do it oh yeah it's
got some weight to it wow it's got some
weight to it check that out okay
look at that okay so pretty simple here
whoa yeah wait wait there it is
alright now that's cool really I feel
like a profession you're doing this it's
like notice the design no no what
seriously it's all I was like when I was
opening I'm like oh this one's broken
this has a mark on it this hat and I'm
like oh yeah these guys go through some
rough and tumble stuff that they do or I
mean fighting for the Empire I'm
surprised it's not even more battle
damage yeah it's really cool very cool
we got I'm gonna turn it around and look
at it because I want this I'm always
unboxing toys that I don't get the key
it's gonna stay in the office
that's leaves on the Jedi Council set so
you'll get to enjoy it I'll get to enjoy
it it's like the Stanley Cup everybody
just gets to enjoy it and move it around
a little bit until someone steals it and
it's not in the office anymore but that
won't be me
no like I will not steal this and put
this on my coffee table
alright guys while Riley finishes
dusting our helmet off I'm gonna rind
you this right here is a gentle giant
Nissan exclusive and this right here is
solo a Star Wars story on DVD and
blu-ray you can own it now go check it
out we'll see you soon on Jedi Council
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]